da bambino volevo fare il progettista
questa tela foto testimonia che dico la
verità dire il vero volevo anche fare il
calciatore di punizioni il vecchio
saggio e il netturbino poi devo dire
diciamo per quanto fosse interessante
nonostante fosse divertente fare gol
racconta le storie girare tutta la notte
aggrappato a un camion
nonostante tutte queste cose molto
interessanti essere nato a palermo negli
anni 80
mi ha dato una enorme voglia di provare
a cambiare il mondo
come si fa a progettare un mondo
migliore
ho cercato di trovare risposte
andando un po in giro quella alla fine
quella che mi sembrava la più
ragionevole era quella di provare a
progettare città migliori perché
guardando un po di dati
le città sono una minuscola percentuale
del sulla superficie del pianeta tipo il
2 per cento dove vivono più del 50 per
cento degli abitanti della terra e dove
si consumano tantissime risorse si
inquina tantissimo e allora provare ad
affrontare quel tipo di problema di può
essere un modo per cambiare
effettivamente il destino della del modo
città intelligenti capaci di rispondere
alle esigenze degli esseri umani pagando
i nostri sogni e le nostre ambizioni
le nostre necessità ma nel rispetto del
pianeta più andavo dritto verso questo
questo modo di pensare il futuro più mi
rendevo conto che in realtà città
proprio come queste sono significa
costruire il privilegio per alcuni
perché se davvero vogliamo provare ad
affrontare il problema dobbiamo guardare
in un'altra direzione un futuro un po
più complicato provare a rendere queste
città intelligenti e viviamo in un
universo un mondo costruito il sud
globale è la sfida perché queste città
all 80 per cento di queste città stanno
al sud ed è generalmente per il sud
globale una condizione
di privazione di risorse i diritti di
opportunità e generalmente lo stato è
quello di costante emergenza emergenza
di risposte immediate che davvero
riescano a migliorare le condizioni le
condizioni giornaliere ma come si fa
anche qui non lo so sicuramente i metodi
che abbiamo utilizzato fino ad oggi non
funzionano comunque ci hanno portato a
questa eredità
nell'arco di questa generazione più di
tre miliardi di persone vivranno in
queste città e noi dobbiamo provare
inventarci qualcosa
e allora proviamo a cambiare punto di
vista
proviamo a vedere le cose sotto un'altra
luce se a sinistra c'è un pezzettino di
questo pianeta fortemente urbanizzato
che ha tutta l'aria di essere totalmente
imputabile è in trasformabile a destra
c'è quel sistema nervoso che anima
questo tessuto in realtà proprio un
pezzettino di sistema nervoso perché
sono soltan e la visualizzazione di
alcune interazione via social network
ecco città e cittadini sono l'una
l'immagine dell'altro diciamo pure
platone e se è ancora vero e oggi sembra
essere ancora vero noi possiamo provare
a interagire con queste persone con
coloro che fanno la città possiamo
provare a curare il tessuto attraverso
questo sistema nervoso
la città è fatto dalle scelte dei
cittadini è fatta dalle loro abitudini
possiamo provare a inserirci da dentro
cambiando le loro esperienze esperienze
che oggi con le nuove tecnologie sono
aumentate che ci consentono di percepire
la realtà in un modo nuovo diverso
spesso migliore della realtà stessa
è una questione di percezione è
possibile farlo io ho il privilegio di
lavorare con dei ragazzi straordinari in
un laboratorio di design dove proviamo a
dare delle risposte a queste domande
oggi vi presento tre soluzioni che
abbiamo immaginato
in uno di questi contesti ai margini
diciamo della dei processi
globalizzazione palermo non è un caso
che sono palermitano e a palermo sono
tornati
palermo e il sud in questo caso
nonostante tutto diventano il luogo
perfetto per provare a trovare strumenti
nuovi
se funziona a palermo funziona
dappertutto allora iniziamo col
affrontare uno dei problemi più gravi
il ciaffico come spesso viene definito
certo non sono il primo non sarà neanche
l'ultimo a utilizzare questa come a
vedere questo come una metafora dello
stare a palermo grandissimi artisti
l'hanno fatto e in effetti la realtà
spesso supera la fantasia
palermo è davvero una città super
trafficata che siamo terzi secondo le
classifiche siamo terzi dietro soltanto
mosca e istanbul
però se andiamo proprio a guardarla c'è
qualcosa che non va perché il tessuto la
scritta e piccola il numero di macchina
enorme la densità e alta dovremmo essere
sicuramente primis e poi andiamo a
vedere quanto i palermitani amano andare
in macchina il 78 per cento dei
trasporti ai tragitti di giornali sono
fatti in macchina se noi ragazzi di
moschee di istanbul devono stare attenti
perché ora schizzi amo noi in prima
posizione
comunque a parte queste classifiche
dell'infamia è chiaro che il traffico
non è il problema della nostra città è
il problema di tante città io penso che
nel sud del mondo i problemi principali
sono comunque quelli sempre legati a
corruzione e mafie ma sicuramente il
traffico e castrante per lo sviluppo di
una città la difficoltà di collegarsi
una città non accessibile una città che
non va diritti
oltre a questo chiaramente è un problema
legato alle risorse produrre auto
consumare energie non rinnovabili è una
minaccia per l'ambiente è una minaccia
per la sicurezza degli abitanti delle
città che si fa si migliorano i mezzi di
trasporto pubblico i mezzi di trasporto
di masse st 9 m però generalmente
soprattutto in contesti molto
storicizzati come i nostri
e ogni volta che si scava si trova un
anfora i cantieri durano all'infinito e
poi comunque il problema della
corruzione c'è sempre
questi cantieri durano tantissime poi
quando finiscono finalmente le città
sono completamente diverse sono cambiati
perché la città sono fatte da loro
cittadini che per un motivo o per
l'altro hanno lasciato a casa la
macchina e sperano prima o poi di
lasciare anche la fermata o quelli che
ogni giorno da veri eroi sfidano sti
mostri di due tonnellate con le
biciclette in e allora se è questa
l'esperienza di muoversi in modo diverso
sostenibile nei confronti del pianeta in
città allora non abbiamo dove andare
perché è chiaro che non è possibile
convincere quel 78 per cento a cambiare
le proprie abitudini
allora che facciamo proviamo a guardare
la cosa da un altro punto di vista
allora abbiamo detto che è una sfida
impegnativa per se stessi perché ci si
scontra con la città e alla fine non c'è
nessun premio non mi è mai capitato di
arrivare in bicicletta alla posta e
qualcuno mi facesse festa però se
proviamo a ripartire da questo quindi è
una sfida che richiede impegno ed è
potrebbe dovrebbe richiedere un premio
mia nonna mi diceva sempre se fai il
bravo alla fine marmellata benissimo
facciamo un gioco è un gioco muoversi in
città è un gioco se si usano soltanto
mezzi di trasporto sostenibile muoversi
a piedi in bicicletta come zii pubblici
car sharing car pooling e allora vengono
date questa è un'applicazione per
smartphone che da informazioni rispetto
al costo in termini di tempo di energia
di costo economico quanto posta muoversi
con un mezzo rispetto all'altro ma
mentre ci si muove si fanno punti in
funzione del sistema di trasporto
utilizzato questi punti attivano delle
sfide
ecco che cosa si vince premi veri e
propri premi messi a disposizione da una
rete di sponsor locali aziende piccole e
medie che hanno tutto l'interesse a
ravvivare la mobilità sostenibile perché
se ci si muove a piedi con i due talenti
si fa anche il tempo per fare la spesa e
oltre a non inquinare la città
ovviamente
e allora per loro diventa uno strumento
per
conoscere meglio i propri clienti
conoscere meglio e avere un accesso
diverso al rapporto con con i cittadini
e noi abbiamo fatto diversi test abbiamo
preso a campione l'università degli
studi di palermo i suoi ragazzi abbiamo
preso un campione di questi abbiamo
fatto molte sperimentazioni
alla fine il risultato è stato
incredibile almeno andando come eravamo
partiti perché ovviamente tutti diciamo
palermo
farete mai nulla però alla fine i
ragazzi ha avuto l'applicazione avuto
una redemption da buona applicazione di
intrattenimento i ragazzi hanno
effettivamente migliorato le proprie
abitudini minimizzando il loro impatto
del 50 per cento che come se fosse le
targhe alterne ma non abbiamo messo
nessun semaforo in più nessuna multa
nessun vigile nessuna videocamera abbia
fatto giocare
gli abbiamo dato un motivo valido
abbiamo trovato diversi motivi validi
per far interagire i cittadini in modo
diverso i ragazzi uscivano da casa al
grido andiamo a fare punteggio e hanno
pronto in tutti i modi e fregarci per
prendersi premi senza muoversi in modo
sostenibile ma questo non è ovviamente è
servito per cercare di blindare il gioco
e le regole del gioco
un altra cosa interessante che abbiamo
siamo riusciti a ottenere attraverso
questo strumento nuovo e dati partendo
da una città che ha chiaramente un
problema non indifferente legato al
traffico dati rispetto a un tipo di
mobilità di verso una mobilità
sostenibile
noi oggi sappiamo almeno per quel
campione che abbiamo analizzato quale è
la strada più sicura da fare in
bicicletta per raggiungere un
dipartimento un altro o quella da fare a
piedi uguale linea dell'autobus è l'ala
più diciamo che ha più problemi magari
durante un certo periodo del giorno
ovviamente in città non ci si muove
soltanto per andare al lavoro o per
andare all'università ci si muove anche
per cose bellissime come queste quindi
tutto quello che riguarda il turismo è
che spesso è un driver importante in
contesti come il nostro ora succede
spesso che si incontrano poveri turisti
tedeschi con i calzini e sandali girare
tipo zombie in vico ii
che sono distanti appena 500 metri dalla
cappella palatina el sono completamente
persi anelano informazione semplicemente
un informazione dove andare e nel
momento giusto possibilmente e magari
che qualcuno gli desse un consiglio su
un itinerario che si fa segnaletica si
prova a dare informazioni nel modo
classico però questo richiede dei costi
di manutenzione e allora si prendano i
bambini e si spargono per la città e
facendo da ciceroni a me l'hanno fatto
fare una frustrazione terribile allora è
proviamo a immaginare un'esperienza
diversa del previste dalla città servono
informazioni e ci sono spesso li
chiamano bendata non sono così spesso
così i raffinati come vorremmo per cui è
un lavoro veramente da scavatore per cui
serve anche una comunità che riesca a da
tenere aggiornati i dati legati al
patrimonio storico artistico ed esistono
già comunità che offrono il proprio
tempo per cercare di migliorare
l'accoglienza della propria città e poi
serve un po di matematica per cercare di
tutte queste informazioni complesse
offrirle in un modo semplice e per
esempio l'algoritmo dei percorsi minimi
del professor de x3 è un inizio e allora
cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo provato a
mettere assieme open data una comunità è
un po di matematica il professor degli
extra ed è venuto fuori uno strumentino
uno strumento che consente di avere
l'informazione giusta al momento giusto
offline nella in tutte le città perché
in tutte le città perché l'applicazione
completamente open sono penn i dati sono
è open il codice e ogni comunità può
candidarsi è inserire il proprio
database
in questo modo dota di fatto la propria
città dell'applicazione
questa è un tentativo di cercare di
migliorare lo speed la nostra ospitalità
e cercare di migliorare l'ospitalità di
tante città del mondo ora è chiaro che
il virtuale aiuta il reale e non è
soltanto fare figo durante eventi social
o altro può avere un impatto
molto più importante e si può applicare
anche alla città questa è una foto di un
quartiere sfortunato di palermo ma
potrebbe essere stata scattata in
qualsiasi altro posto del mondo
borgo vecchio a bari problemi conflitti
sociali in una fortissima evasione
scolastica ma ultimamente noi girando
per questo perche abbiamo contato a
vedere roba strana tipo bambini che
portano a spasso gatti blu renne
impazzite piovere malinconiche è tutta
opera di dell'attività di
un'associazione che da tre laboratori
con bambini dopo scuola è uno street
artist and matt jones lui con una
pazienza invidiabile devo dirvi fa
dipingere i bambini e dentro il
laboratorio e poi li porta fuori a
portare sul muro muro di casa loro del
case dei loro amici dei parenti con
l'aiuto degli amici dei parenti e cambia
questo qualche millimetro della
superficie dell'immobile innescando un
processo che ri ravviva davvero
l'identità del luogo
l'identità della comunità che è un vero
processo di rigenerazione dal basso
ma proprio dai bassi perché sono bambini
piccoli bassi è poi oltre a innescare
quello che può essere uno sviluppo
diverso è davvero sostenibile perché
fatto dalla comunità per la comunità una
cosa straordinaria dov'è il problema che
sono finiti i soldi
l'associazione non ha più risorse per
potere continuare i laboratori e allora
che si fa
dovrebbe essere qualcosa di cui si
occupa alla pubblica amministrazione
però la pubblica amministrazione ha
finito i soldi e allora anche
l'esperienza di trasformare la città che
dovrebbe essere un'esperienza da
pubblica amministrazione si può
trasformare in un'esperienza diversa
noi abbiamo provato a raccontare nel
modo migliore possibile quello che
potevamo fare come fosse un gioco da
ragazzi innescare un cambiamento
profondo della città è come con un
processo giusto un po di colore e
fantasia
i luoghi cambiano
danno speranza quindi abbiamo fatto una
campagna di crowd funding come se
stessimo vendendo l'ultima gingillo
tecnologico con perche straordinari
super personalizzati abbiamo fatto un
video tradotto in 10 lingue non penso
neanche esistessero 10 lingue ma ci
siamo fatti aiutare da amici eravamo
sparsi in giro per il mondo è questa
campagna di crowdfunding è stata vista
in 85 paesi
ogni palermitano all'estero di prima
seconda o terza generazione doveva
sapere cosa stava succedendo nella sua
città e dare una mano in poche settimane
abbiamo raggiunto l'obiettivo economico
l'abbiamo superato sempre di più e 160
per cento e questo ci ha consentito di
attivare nuovi laboratori con anche
nuovi nuovi artisti che sono venuti a
borgo vecchio non lavorato con i
ragazzini
abbiamo lavorato con la loro vera
passione anche che il calcio quindi
forza palermo sa che siamo a catania mi
consentirete di farlo è quindi abbiamo
rimesso a posto anche il campetto di
calcio che era un luogo in cui la
comunità si aggrega ovviamente non
soltanto per giocare a calcio perché una
delle poche piazze del quartiere
anche qui il lavoro fatto dagli artisti
con i ragazzi borgo vecchio si sta
aprendo a nuovi contatti con intanto la
città di palermo e poi con il mondo oggi
vengono artisti a fare pezzi e borgo
vecchio a vedere cosa succede a borgo
vecchio ed è credo la il modo più giusto
per portare un cambiamento progressivo
voglio concludere il mio intervento con
questo graffito che racconta come la
comunità di borgo vecchio abbia tagliato
le barriere che la separavano dal mondo
come vedete ci sono tutti c'è pure un
pokémon è un uomo a forma di cuore
ora ogni trasformazione deve tenere al
centro le persone quelle cose fatte di
carne e ossa sentimenti emozioni se non
ci sono al centro le persone nessuna
trasformazione su questo territorio può
funzionare
noi dobbiamo progettare per il sud
eccone il sud noi dobbiamo avere
coraggio di saltare recinti spingerci
dove possiamo fallire perché altrimenti
non riusciremo mai a progettare il
nostro futuro
grazie a tutti